deuxième épisode de notre petite série
de l'été je vous rappelle le concept je
cherche des questions plus ou moins
sérieuses plus ou moins what the fuck
sur les forums santé et j'irai dans la
bonne humeur et la rigolade évidemment
mais j'y réponds sérieusement et surtout
j'y réponds sans me moquer évidemment
parce que ça sera le premier épisode
était disons généralistes alors si vous
l'avez pas vu bon vous en veux pas un
c'était les vacances tout ça je sais
enfin aller le voir quand même ce nouvel
épisode lui il sera thématisé puisque
c'est un spécial transit et digestion
alors une première chose ce format il a
maintenant un nom vous le savez pas ce
que vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo il
s'appelle d'été si simon
vous avez la réf super et deuxième chose
rester bien jusqu'à la fin parce qu'en
faisant mes recherches pour cette vidéo
je suis tombé sur un mystère
particulièrement étrange je ne vous en
dis pas plus
[Musique]
allez plus ni une ni deux c'est parti
pour la première question bonjour ça
fait quatre jours que j'ai est celle qui
flottent elles sont bien formés et non
liquides mais si je les touche avec un
objet pour voir la consistance ça a
l'air assez vous j'ai lu partout sur
google que les sels flottantes sont un
signe de maladie donc ça me stresse j'ai
déjà eu des épisodes comme celui ci
disparaissent ensuite ms-l revenait à la
normale merci de partager vos
expériences avec les vraies questions
directes ça vous est forcément déjà
arrivé de faire votre petit business aux
toilettes de tirer la chasse est de
constater que les amis que vous venez de
déposer à la piscine s'obstine à faire
la planche petite métaphore sympa et
vous avez même sûrement déjà transpiré
du cif en entendant quelqu'un toquer à
la porte en faisant des bruits de plus
en plus belliqueux pour signifier que là
il faudrait que vous lui laissez la
place sauf que évidemment impossible de
ressortir avec ce truc qui refait
surface sans arrêt comme manuel valls
ça s'appelle la malédiction de
l'étranger
mais au delà du côté handicap social ce
qui inquiète cette personne si je résume
c'est est-ce que c'est grave oui parce
que je vous le rappelle tout crottes
plonger dans des toilettes reçoit une
poussée vers le fond est cool c'est le
principe d'archimède
alors pourquoi des fois ça ne se passe
pas comme ça il ya deux explications
soit votre caca et plein de gaz
intestinaux un peu comme un beignet hop
route auquel cas ça donne un effet
gilles est plongée vous savez quand
c'est gonflé bad ça remonte à la surface
dans ce cas-là n'y a pas d'inquiétude
avant soit votre caca et plein de grèce
ça modifie sa densité et du coup dit
flotte et là encore il ya plusieurs
explications possibles la première c'est
que vous avez peut-être juste un peu
forcé sur la junk food et la boue crasse
la deuxième c'est que vous avez du mal à
assimiler les graisses peut-être
temporairement et que ça va rentrer dans
l'ordre tout seul et la dernière
effectivement c'est qu'il peut y avoir
une maladie qui perturbe l'absorption
des graisses donc comme d'habitude pas
de panique mettez vous un petit peu à la
diète surveiller et puis si ça persiste
ou que ça devient systématique allez en
parler à votre médecin tranquillement
bonjour j'aimerais vous parler d'une
maladie ou plutôt un problème qui me
colle à la peau depuis quelques temps
vous savez que l'être humain se base sur
ce qu'il voit touche en temps et sans
alors dans mon cas j'ai eu plusieurs
remarques quant à mon odeur corporelle
et ça m'a éloigné de la vie sociale sans
savoir comment et pourquoi depuis
quelques années je dégage une odeur
corporelle très forte et je reçois
beaucoup de remarques par rapport à ça
que ce soit sur le chemin du travail au
travail par mes collègues ma chef
partout où je vais je ne manque pas de
me faire dévisager par les gens qui
m'entourent
car je sens toujours la transpiration
une odeur semblable à l'oignon ou au
poireau alors là ensuite la personne
raconte que sous la pression de ses
collègues et de sa chef elle a dû
démissionner puis elle poursuit en
faisant des recherches sur internet sur
des sites américains j'en ai appris plus
sur les odeurs corporelles et les
raisons qui font que la transpiration
soit malodorantes j'ai découvert deux
maladies qui pouvait être la source de
mon problème là bromide rose et l'a10
bio intestinale j'ai également appris
que certaines personnes pouvaient sentir
le poisson pourri à cause du syndrome tm
à moment déjà on est d'accord cette
histoire elle est dingue et
et rama tic & bass h et comme ça on mes
recherches pour cette vidéo je suis
tombé sur plusieurs autres témoignages
de personnes qui explique qu'elles ne
sortent plus de chez elles ou qu'elles
ont elles aussi perdu leur boulot à
cause de leur odeur on sait que notre
odeur corporelle elle est unique et
qu'elle est déterminée par plein de
choses on avait parlé dans une vidéo sur
le sujet allez voir ça si vous voulez je
vous mets le lien dans la description
parmi ces trucs qui influencent notre
d'heure ya ce qu'on mange parce qu'il ya
des substances qui sont produites par
notre gestion et qui sont aussi rejeté
dans notre transpiration par exemple du
coup en cas de 10 biaudos intestinale
comme l'on parle cette personne c'est à
dire si on a un déséquilibre au niveau
des bactéries et de tous les
micro-organismes qu'on a dans les
intestins et qui nous aident à digérer
ça peut se faire sentir
littéralement la théorie c'est que dans
ces cas là à les substances produites
par la digestion elles sont pas les
mêmes du coup l'odeur n'est pas la même
et parfois ça peut sentir mambé a et
pour cette histoire de syndrome de
l'odeur du poisson pourri ça existe et
pour le coup on sait exactement comment
ça marche c'est le déficit d'une enzyme
très particulière qui empêche
l'organisme de métaboliser correctement
une substance qui s'appelle la tri meti
la mine il se trouve que cette substance
bas et centrait fort le poisson du coup
comme lé pas dégrader s accumulent et
elle finit par ressortir par la
transpiration mais aussi par l'uriné ou
la respiration avant de passer à la
question suivante en faire une petite
pause pour parler non pas de notre santé
mais de celle d'un de nos fidèles
compagnons notre note mac pour le coup
parce que je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai
rien quand vous avez un coup de mou
quand vous avez quelque chose qui va pas
vous allez chez votre médecin mais quand
c'est votre mac vous faites quoi eh ben
il se trouve que cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par cleanmymac et que
cleanmymac c'est un peu le médecin de
votre mac si vous sentez qu'il est pas
en forme vous lancer l'appli et elle
fait des analyses
alors pas des prises de sang ou des
radios mais elle scanne votre mac pour
voir là où il ya des soucis ce genre
pour trouver ce qui ralentit votre mac
par exemple elle va checker et tous vos
fichiers pour trouver les vieux machins
les téléchargements à complet les
fichiers cash
bible les doublons voir les tripes long
les quadruples on les trucs qui servent
à rien qu'ils prennent plein de place et
c'est la pluie abat aussi rechercher les
logiciels malveillants qui peuvent
rendre votre mac malades et les
applications qui lui pompe le plus
d'énergie celles qui prennent de la
place et que vous n'utilisez jamais etc
etc voilà ça c'est le diagnostic comme
chez le médecin après il va vous
expliquer ce qui se passe par exemple
avec la fonction télescope il vous
montre visuellement vos fichiers qui
prennent le plus de place et après place
aux traitements il nettoie tous ça et
votre mac retrouve la pêche mais il vaut
mieux prévenir que guérir vous savez ça
si vous êtes des habitués de la chaîne
bat pour ça il ya la fonction menu qui
surveille l'état de santé de votre mac
et qui vous prévient s'il ya quelque
chose qui va par un peu comme si on
prenait régulièrement votre tension
votre fréquence cardiaque etc sauf que
là ça surveille l'état du stockage du
disque dur du processeur de la ram de la
mémoire etc voilà cleanmymac ça existe
depuis 14 ans et c'est un des premiers
outils de nettoyage de ce genre et des
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde si
vous voulez tester je vous mets le lien
vers la version d'évaluation gratuite
dans la description de cette vidéo
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin de
votre mac mais partez pas tout de suite
parce que la vidéo est pas fini alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a ensuite vu mon jour je
mange trois kiwi tous les soirs et non
le matin pour mac constipation et c'est
très efficace mais je voudrais savoir
s'il ya un autrui aussi performant du
pruneau c'est pas terrible à consommer
en période d'été où les kiwis sont hors
saison et donc très cher merci de vos
conseils alors avant toute chose je
tiens à féliciter cette personne pour
l'attention qu'elle porte à la fois à
l'environnement et à son transit c'est
admirable je vais répondre à sa question
mais avant puisque vous êtes tous là je
vais me permettre de redonner quelques
petits conseils pour éviter la
constipation d'abord boire de l'eau
c'est indispensable pour plein de choses
et notamment pour faire de belles celle
bien moulé ensuite faire au moins un peu
d'activité physique tous les jours si on
en a les capacités évidemment ne
serait-ce que marcher de façon un petit
peu rapide parce que rester immobile ça
ralentit notre transit et vous allez
voir pourquoi c'est pas bon oui parce
que le conseil suivant c'est de ne pas
se retenir pourquoi parce que c'est dans
la toute dernière portion des intestins
que la majorité de l'eau qui est contenu
dans notre caca à ce moment-là et
réabsorber par les parois quand vous
avez envie d'aller aux toilettes et que
vous vous retenez ou quand votre transit
les ralentis à votre caca il passe
beaucoup plus de temps que d'habitude
dans cet endroit très précis donc il ya
plus d'eau que d'habitude qui est
réabsorber donc votre caca il devient de
plus en plus dur et vous risquez d'être
constipé retenez bien ce que dit le
poète vous y allez vous y allez y en a
même qui disent qu'on peut jean
redresser ou éduquer ses intestins en
allant tous les jours aux toilettes à la
même heure mais bon déjà si vous vous
retenez pas à quand c'est le moment
c'est déjà deux et puis dernière chose à
l'alimentation évidemment varié riche en
fibres donc des fruits oui mais aussi
des légumes et des céréales mais bon la
question c'est les fruits de saison bon
bah en ce moment les fruits qui peuvent
le plus ces décès les prunes les figues
les cerises le raisin et la rhubarbe
mais aussi les abricots les pommes et
les poires par exemple voilà ça c'est
les fruits d'été du coup on est en été
on pourra en reparler à l'automne si ça
va pas mieux non seulement ah oui et
alors petite astuce le truc qui marche
en toute saison c'est les fruits secs
alors les pruneaux par exemple mais
notre camarade n'a pas l'air hyper chaud
pour ça il ya aussi les figues et les
dates cadeaux bonjour comme le titre
l'indiqué j'ai mis une brosse à dents
dans mon cul comme lubrifiant j'ai
utilisé du gel douche j'ai lu sur
internet que c'était mauvais de fer same
way oui oui alors mais vous nous fait
perdre notre temps en fait là non bon il
s'agit manifestement d'un petit
plaisantin mais j'en profite quand même
pour vous rappeler cette règle d'or
n'introduisait dans votre anus que ce
que vous êtes sûr de pouvoir retirer
facile et idéalement quelque chose qui
est profilé à cet effet est clairement
pas le cas d'une brosse à dents et je
vous parle même pas du désastre en terme
d'hygiène bucco-dentaire bonjour j'ai
une grande interrogation j'ai été à la
selle le 25 février 2022 une boule aux
valises et jaune sortait de mais celle
de la forme d'un tic tac deux fois plus
gros et de couleur jaune en ouvrant
cette boule l'intérieur et d'un blanc
pur à moitié farineux ayant des douleurs
inexpliquées depuis huit ans je
m'interroge si cela ne serait pas dû à
un parasite ou autres dans l'estomac et
les intestins en sachant qu'en 2021
j'avais fait une analyse de sel pour
voir s'il n'y avait rien d'anormal tout
était ok géré fait deux nouvelles
analyses de selles le 2 mars
sans vous le jaune et le 4 mars avec
deux boules jaunes ils n'ont rien trouvé
d'anormal
voyez vous ça déboule jaune dans le caca
voilà un mystère bien mystérieux que je
brûle littéralement d'élucider
spontanément je note trois éléments
particulièrement signifiant premièrement
cette personne est très précis sur les
dates et notamment sur les dates
auxquelles elle fait caca c'est une
bonne chose on a beaucoup à apprendre de
nos matières fécales et la médecine
moderne le néglige beaucoup trop
deuxièmement cette personne n'hésite
manifestement pas à mettre la main à la
pâte et à disséquer ses propres celles
pour avoir une idée très précise de ce
qu'elle contient
c'est une bonne chose on a beaucoup à
apprendre de nos matières fécales et la
médecine moderne le néglige beaucoup
trop et troisièmement c'est peut-être le
plus important il est possible que cette
personne ne mange parfois du maïs en
fait est qu'elles soient pas au courant
que l' enveloppe autour des grains de
maïs et de la cellulose et qu'on n'est
pas équipé pour digérer la cellule
autres donc que si elles marchent pas
bien la retrouver des grains maïs entier
dans son caca alors attention je répète
ce que j'ai dit dans la première vidéo
je ne fais pas de diagnostic plein de
raisons notamment parce que je suis pas
médecin donc si ça vous arrive allez
quand même en parler à votre médecin
la d'humanisme d'ailleurs en faisant mes
recherches j'ai trouvé ça sur un autre
forum salat de 2018 donc j'ai peut-être
réellement mis à jour le mystère des
boules jaunes dans le gard à moins que
ce soit juste la même personne qui
cherche désespérément une réponse depuis
des années en tout cas l enquête
continue n'hésitez pas à me contacter si
vous avez des infos sur ce sujet bien
sûr d'autant plus que je viens de tomber
là dessus ça date de 2009 et regardez ça
voilà qui relance le oui non mais c'est
bon on a compris maintenant voilà
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo ce sera de nouveau 1 dt 6 6 mo et
puis ensuite on repassera à un format
plus classique d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres mettez
vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]